nous avons une situation bien sûr pas maintenant
il fait à peine noir dehors
kate vit dans une bulle il s'agit
de servir son mari et elle s'est en quelque
sorte perdue je suis comme Martha Stewart
avec un gros slip laissez-moi vous dire
quelque chose à propos de Martha Stewart elle
gère la prison comme  un patron que j'ai vu une arme à feu est
un peu un retour en arrière c'est la
quintessence de la tenue Kate c'est un
petit deux pièces en coton vichy Prada
le combo sac et chaussure coordonné
Manolo Blahnik petit slingback et puis
ce sac Kate Spade est une femme classique de
Greenwich  sac à main chaque fois que je
regarde dans une paire de jumelles, c'est
une autre mission, elle est très assemblée
et très conventionnelle, cette tenue est
après qu'elle a une transformation dans sa
vie, elle est glamour mais elle est toujours
Kate
vous